yeah I gotta say I'm a big I'm a big
supporter of gun rights but frankly I am
ashamed of the gun rights advocates who
were protesting in Richmond yesterday I
am just embarrassed by them I mean think
about it the media had been rooting so
hard for there to be violence during
this rally Democrats are pushing forth
the governor of Virginia was really
pushing for it declared a state of
emergency ahead of time and then the
rally happens and there's no violence at
all no violence you people at the rally
if you went to the rally you really
thought it was it was polite to
embarrass the media and Democrats by
being peaceful and just having a normal
rally and then going home I think it's
pretty tacky I have to say it's almost
as tacky as the time when when nobody
shot up a screening of the Joker as
media had obviously been hoping for I
mean you couldn't have at least burned a
car or you know shot out a window or
something maybe attacked somebody with a
crowbar you know the kind of stuff that
antifa does of course when TV does it
the media never notices but if you had
done it the media would've loved that
it'd be the only thing they talked about
for the next three weeks and you took
that opportunity away from them they
they Bank so much on it and then you
just you you I don't know I found it
rude I just find it rude maybe I was
raised differently
I was raised well my parents always told
me is if somebody has a negative opinion
of you don't embarrass them by refusing
to live down to it and you know but
that's an old-fashioned way of being
raised like I said it's just it's just
kids aren't raised that way anymore and
it's really sad just had to get that off
my chest anyway yes the gun rights rally
did happen in Richmond yesterday in
response to the gun control measures by
Democrats in the state and it was a
peaceful event one where not only was a
peaceful actually but they but they they
cleaned up after themselves which is
another thing that often time oftentimes
it had left-wing protests little things
like cleaning up after yourself doesn't
that maybe they did they don't focus
quite as much on that but clean up after
themselves and went home and and that
was it
and it wasn't
very frustrating for the media and I
want to talk about that and about what
also what I think is an extremely
significant political scandal attached
to this or related to it and we're gonna
get to all that but first a word from
Tommy John's you know for me the most
important thing when it comes to
clothing really when it comes to any
kind of clothing is comfort okay because
I'm the one that's gotta be wearing the
clothes all day I'm not gonna be looking
at the clothes most of the day I'm gonna
be wearing it and so for me I want to
make sure first and foremost that it's
comfortable and this is doubly true when
it comes to what you weigh or what you
wear over or under the the outer layer
your underwear that's I think comforts
even more important there when it comes
to comfort down below there's underwear
and then there's Tommy John the
revolutionary clothing brand that's
redefined comfort for Americans
everywhere including me the people at
Tommy John were nice enough to you know
they were say send me a few samples of
their products and I especially
appreciate the undershirt which I'm
which I have me wearing right now it's
breathable it's a great fit and here's
what I like is that doesn't get all
stretched out in the wash and out of
shape and mangled unlike every other
undershirt I've ever I've ever owned
this one is you know maintains that
shape and that great fit no matter how
many times you wash it and you should
wash it by the way as as often as you
wear it just so you know Tommy John
focuses on the 3x fabric fit and
function Tommy John obsesses over every
little detail and stitch by using
proprietary fabrics that perform like
nothing you've ever worn before and when
you wear it you could tell that they
obsess over all those details because
you could tell that this is a lot of
effort and time has been put into
creating what you're wearing
as a result Tommy John's men's and
women's underwear sports a no wedgie
guarantee comfortable there's a stay-put
waist bands at a range of fabrics that
are luxuriously soft feather-light
moisture wicking breathable and designed
to move with you not against you so
there you want your underwear to work
with you
in other words Tommy John is so
confident in their underwear that if you
don't love your first pair you can get a
full refund with their best
pair you'll ever wear or it's or it's
free that's the guarantee if you prefer
to shop in stores you can find them in
over 1200 retail locations across the
country including Nordstrom stores
nationwide
once you go Tommy John you won't go back
try it and you'll see that I'm right
hurry did Tommy John calm slash Walsh
for 20% off your first order that's
Tommy John comm slash walls for 20% off
Tommy John comm slash Walsh alright so
the gun rights rally happened yesterday
a huge turnout but not much to say about
the rally itself it went off without a
hitch
you know there was there was a bunch of
people there yes they were carrying
weapons no it didn't devolve into
violence
these were lawful gun owners responsible
gun owners and and they're perfectly
capable it turns out of of coming
together and and assembling without
randomly shooting people you know if you
didn't know that's uh that they are
capable of that so they they made their
point they made their voice heard and
then they went home
I think the notable stuff the stuff
worth talking about is everything
surrounding it namely the governor of
Virginia who tried to gin up fear and
paranoia about this rally and when the
the fear-mongering was proven to be
baseless he tried to take credit for the
fact that it was peaceful
so yesterday after after the rally north
and put out a statement saying quote we
are all thankful that today passed
without incident the team successfully
de-escalated what could have been a
volatile situation I will continue to
listen to the voices of Virginians and
we'll do everything in my power to keep
our Commonwealth safe yeah I really love
that this is great
this is I'm gonna do this from now on
whenever I go somewhere and there's no
violence I'm gonna take credit for
de-escalating so you know I just got
back from Kroger got the toilet paper we
needed don't worry everything stayed
calm nobody was hurt I was able to
successfully de-escalate the situation
don't worry no that's
he says it was a potentially volatile
situation now I wasn't there but I did
follow up pretty closely on social media
I saw plenty of footage of the event I
didn't see anything that looked even
remotely volatile I didn't just what I
saw were people mostly cheerfully making
their voice heard getting their point
across about gun rights there was
chanting and singing they said the
Pledge of Allegiance which was very
upsetting for some leftists on Twitter
it turns out but I didn't see anything
volatile I didn't see anything I didn't
even see anything that looked like it
almost could have turned violent but all
of this would be more funny I suppose if
it weren't for the corruption involved
here the governor of Virginia Northam he
of blackface and infanticide same as I
said declared a state of emergency
leading up to the rally even though
there's no apparent reason for it here's
what he said in part when he declared
the state of emergency last week he said
the anticipated effects of the potential
convergence of tens of thousands of
demonstrators on Capitol Square some of
whom may not come to assemble peacefully
constitutes an emergency as described in
the Code of Virginia therefore by virtue
of the authority vested in me by the
Constitution of Virginia so on and so
forth
I am proclaimed the state of emergency
will exist starting on January 17th
through January 21st okay some of whom
may not have come to assemble peacefully
did he have any credible intelligence
that there were people coming who
weren't going to be peaceful d-did he
have anything other than a prejudice
against gun owners if he had no such
intelligence that he just declared a
state of emergency as a political tool
to gin up fear towards a group of
citizens who were exercising their First
Amendment right unless you're gonna tell
me that every time there's a protest he
declares a state of emergency because
who knows maybe some of them won't be
peaceful which is true in general I mean
single day you know people come to the
capital of Virginia and for all you know
some of them might not be peaceful so
why not declare a state of emergency
every single day if you're declaring
declaring a state of emergency it should
be for a specific reason like a specific
threat a credible threat that you
received if there wasn't again if there
was no such threat if there's no
credible specific reason for declaring a
state of emergency then this is a
scandal this is an abuse of power far
worse than anything Trump has done in
office now of course we know that
Northam is never held accountable for
anything he says or does this guy is
like we talked about Teflon Don Teflon
Donald Trump but this guy's Teflon - you
got black face and Fanta side gets
reelected and now we know that this
isn't gonna hurt him either
but if we had a real meet if we had a
real news media they would demand that
the governor of Virginia release
whatever intelligence whatever threats
he supposedly had you know whatever
whatever justifies the state of
emergency that he declared he should
release and if he can't or he doesn't
then we're gonna know that this was that
there was either no reason for it or
there was very flimsy reason and the
real reason underlying all of that is
just that it's just it's very obvious
he's trying to make people afraid he
wants you to think that when a bunch of
gun owners get together well it's an
emergency you know it's a powder keg and
we're just on the verge of chaos every
moment but to be declaring a state of
emergency
officially for that reason is again a
enormous abuse of power speaking of
power switching gears here here's a
Alexandria Kaiser Cortez speaking
recently at some kind of event and she
had a she made an interesting I think
admission listen to this to be ethical
if you're a billionaire today
the thing that you need to do is give up
control and power so I don't want your
money
as much as we want your power the people
not me that's gonna get cut and clip yes
yes it will
AOC yes yes it will we will get cut and
clipped we want your power she says
which is one of the most horrific aliy
honest things we've heard from a
politician in quite some time it's
always we say we want politicians to be
honest and I want them to be honest but
it's always horrifying when they are
because then you hear stuff like that
and yeah fine she corrects herself and
says no no not me I don't want your
power fine all right I'll let her
correct herself I don't want to jump on
someone's case for a slip of the tongue
but what actually does she mean when she
says we who is we you know she says well
she says the people she's referring to
the people all right well what do you
mean by the people are the people a
monolith that can be given power
whatever that means can you take power
from one individual person and then give
it to the people well we know from past
experience that generally when Democrats
especially socialists talk about not
that there's much difference between the
two anymore when they talk about the
people what they mean is the government
the state so she's saying that she wants
the power of billionaires not just not
just the money but the power to go to
the people but what that means what we
know that means is the government so
when she said we she really did mean
herself because she's a part of the
government she's an agent of the state
and I think this brings up an important
point which is which is this all of this
demonizing of the wealthy all this stuff
about taking money from the wealthy
taking power from them well okay but
when you advocate for that you're
advocating that the government get
bigger and stronger and more power
and this is something I you know I wish
especially Democrat voters would be able
to understand that you as a peon me as a
peon
we remain peons in both scenarios
so whether billionaires have all that
money and power or the government takes
it either way you know we're still the
peasants in the situation unfortunately
I don't like it but that's that's the
reality
AOC and and Bernie and her ilk they
aren't going to make they're not gonna
make us any richer or us any more
powerful than we already are or aren't
they're talking about this for
themselves you know this is something
they benefit from it's like we talked
about last week with a student loan and
this week - I think the so-called
student loan forgiveness and we talked
about how it's not really forgiveness
it's transfer you're taking this the
debt student loan debt and you're
transferring it from the people who took
out the loan and it would seem in a by
all rights should be the ones to pay
back and you're transferring that debt
to somebody else and by Elizabeth
Warren's plan and Bernie Sanders plan
it's gonna be those dreaded billionaires
and millionaires again so it's really a
transfer and with this with what
Alexandria Kaiser Cortez is talking
about again it's a transfer it's not
it's not taking away the wealth or the
and the power from billionaires it's
transferring it from billionaires to
herself and the government and if you
think you're gonna be any better off
with the government being more powerful
than it is then I think you just haven't
been paying very close attention before
we move on I want to tell you about
something that we're doing over here at
the deli wire that's really important if
you're a regular listener you have of
course heard me talk about pro-life
issues and my unwavering position on
pro-life issues and and the reason why I
focus on it so much is that you know
since roe v wade passed over 60 million
unborn children have been killed in the
womb 60 million that's that's a that's a
number so large that it's
hard for us to conceptualize but 60
million people were talking about and
last year the left one even further off
the cliff passing the New York State law
that allows abortion up to birth there
was a law in Illinois that would allow
partial birth abortion which is an
utterly barbaric procedure and to make
matters more intense pro-life advocates
are actively being targeted by the
pro-abortion left when Ben Shapiro spoke
of the march for life last year our
advertisers were targeted by the left
and several of them pulled their ads
from the program because of it this was
not the first time it's not gonna be the
last time that we are attacked in an
attempt to shut down pro-life voices
we're also not the only targets of
course live action is one of the biggest
voices in the pro-life movement of a big
fan of live actions work I have been for
a long time they do some of the most
important work in the pro-life movement
whether it's raising awareness and
education on the abortion issue
undercover videos that expose Planned
Parenthood that was my first like a lot
of people that was their first
introduction to live action's work
several years ago when they were doing
these undercover videos and they were
one of the first groups to go in and do
these undercover videos of Planned
Parenthood so and they're paying the
price for they've been banned from
advertising on Twitter they have seen
their advertising efforts and their
online distribution restricted on
several platforms across the internet
because of the work they do that is why
our daily wire.com members are really
important
your membership helps us say no to
advertisers who you know cave2 left-wing
ideologies if they're advertisers that
are gonna cave we're gonna try to
control what we talk about whether it's
on this show or any other show with with
your support you know it's it's it's
it's easy for us to say we don't need
them we keep our pro-life message from
being you keep our pro-life message I
should say from being from being
cancelled and instead it grows even
louder that's why from now until January
31st a portion of any daily wire.com
membership will be donated to live
action with promo code live action it's
of course Li ve AC tion live action to
support awareness and education around
the world on this issue so join daily
wire
come and make your pro-life voice heard
okay one other thing
one other thing to mention before we
read some emails I happened across this
on Twitter someone posted a screenshot
of a tweet don't know who who posted
this originally he doesn't really matter
it's more the the sentiment that I want
to address a common sentiment and so
this tweet says male privilege is
wearing the same outfit in multiple
times two events while girls can't wear
the same dress twice no matter how cute
it is okay so that was the tweet talking
about male privilege and the the the you
know the you hear this kind of thing a
lot it's related to the unrealistic
beauty standards that women deal with
all the supposed pressure on them to be
stylish and trendy and all that etcetera
and so forth here's my point I want to
say this maybe for the benefit of some
female listeners if they weren't aware
and my message is this as men you know
we don't care one bit at all really
how stylish your clothes are we don't
care about you being trendy and stylish
we don't need you to wear a bunch of
makeup right I mean the makeup industry
is multi-billion dollar industry so
women are spending lots of money on
makeup and I guess a lot of women feel
like they you know feel pressure like
they have to put a lot of makeup on
before they leave the house you're not
doing that for us because we really we
don't need that we don't care and I
really am speaking for all men when I
said I think I can speak for you know
maybe there are a few outliers but I
guess big for almost all men and in fact
we would actually prefer it if if you
cared less than you do about about what
you wear so my point is but you can care
our from what you want to care it's up
to you my I'm just my point is the
pressure that you feel it's not from us
you know it's from you guys that's
pressure you're putting on each other
so there's this this thing that I've
noticed of in this culture of women
putting pressure on each other to act a
certain way or do a certain thing or buy
a certain product or dress a certain way
putting pressure on each other and then
blaming men for the stress that their
own self-imposed rule causes them
meanwhile we're over here like we don't
care if you do that or not don't don't
don't look at us I mean this is women
who are you know very focused on how
they look when they go out in public
maybe for the men get end up getting
blamed for it so I guess at some level
their women feel like they're doing it
for men but I also feel like they must
know that really they're doing it for
each other they're not really doing it
for us because as I said we don't notice
and we don't care and the reason was so
it's not male privilege yeah a man I
guess now I mean a woman who feels like
what she she can't wear the same outfit
twice ever that seems pretty extreme
that's gonna get very expensive but it
is true that men you know as men like
you know we don't have much compunction
about wearing the same outfit multiple
times as we're not worried about it we
don't have that stress but if that's a
privilege that we have it's a privilege
that is available to you as well it's
just we we've taken advantage of that
privilege because we just don't care
about it and we're not looking at each
other and judging each other for that
now you know I mean I could be around a
guy every day for two weeks and he could
wear the same outfit every single day
and it would it would probably take me
about seven or eight days before I
noticed he could get away with seven or
eight days of wearing the exact same
outfit and I probably wouldn't notice
after a while I might and then when I do
I might start putting it together and
say wait a second I don't think I've
seen him wear anything but that now that
you mentioned it and then once I noticed
that yeah I'm gonna make fun of him
because it's my it's my duty as a man to
make fun of him for that but it's not a
big deal
and we
just laugh about it and I don't think he
goes home and cries in his bathroom that
he got made fun of I think it's just he
understands that gays been wearing the
same outfit and so he's gonna get made
fun of for it it's fine it's just what
men do my point is that as women I mean
you could have the same approach if you
wanted to so I just I wouldn't I think
there are a lot of things it's not just
this there's a lot of pressure that
women feel in society a lot of
oppression that they might feel that
again gets blamed on men but I think
really comes mostly from themselves from
other women
another example be in the workplace I
always this is one of the one of the
common tropes that you hear from
feminists is on top of the unrealistic
unrealistic beauty standards which again
are almost entirely made by women for
women those those beauty standards but
another common trope is it just thinking
about in the workplace where women feel
you know hostility if they speak too
much and they get talked over a lot
that's a big thing that you hear it's a
trope that women are getting talked over
in the workplace every time I hear that
I think I mean I don't doubt that you
get talked over but is it really by men
doing that women they've done Studies on
this and women's on average they say
like 20,000 more words a day than men
they do a lie or no maybe it's 20,000
words totals but be a lot of words but
they women's use speak a lot more than
men they're much more verbal than men
are so most of the time what I notice
you know whether it's in a work
environment or socially yeah people get
talked over but seems to me that the
people who do the talking over more
often are women just because they have
more to say so they've just got more
words they have to get out in a day and
so they're gonna end up trampling over
each other in the talking whereas men I
mean me I could go I could go six days
and say nothing if it were up to me now
doing this job it's kind of hard
but if I didn't you know if I was living
in a cave or something by myself and I
had no one to talk to
I'd be fine I don't know I could go
indefinite amount of time and say
nothing honestly I think a lot of men
are like that now there are talkative
men but a really talkative man you
notice look if you if you if you if you
encounter a really talkative man you
think wow this guy doesn't shut up it
really you really notice it because it's
not usually it's not common for men
whereas women are more talkative which
is fine but again that's so if you're
getting talked over you feel like you
can't get a word in edgewise probably
it's because of other women that are
doing that to you it's probably not men
so I'm not saying that you know men can
be jerks and they could be judgmental
and all those things as well
but I think we need to stop and reassess
the the obstacles that women face
especially socially you stop and
reassess and see how much of that
actually is coming from the patriarchy
for men and how much of it actually is
coming from you know from inside the
house as it were inside the the female
house I think a lot of it is is imposed
on women by women all right let's move
on to emails Matt wall show at gmail.com
his email address from Andrew I had some
questions yesterday about Star Wars and
so I got a lot of emails which I
appreciate from Star Wars fans answering
my questions this is one from Andrew
says let's start with the helmet thing
first I'd like to point out that I made
the point that only in Star Wars I
couldn't figure out why only the bad
guys wear cool helmets and masks and I
said maybe that's why people go the
dark-sided because they want to wear the
cool costumes and all the cool costumes
are with the bad guys
for some reason Andrew says let's start
with the helmet thing first I like to
point out that good guy characters have
cool helmets in Episode six Leia gets a
sweet bounty-hunter helmet in Episode
two and three the Clone Trooper follow
the same customs
as the stormtroopers and where they're
sweet helmets all the time
now the reason Darth Vader wears a
helmet is because he has to do is head
is permanently disfigured as it isn't
even functioning properly anymore well
he doesn't have to write it said that's
more of a vanity thing this doesn't want
people to see a disfigured head which I
don't get that either because if you're
a bad guy you're a super arch villain if
there's any time you can get away with
having a disfigured disgusting scarred
face it's when you're a super villain so
if you're super villain just embrace it
kylo Ren has a cool helmet in Cannon
because he idolizes Vader and wants to
be like him in the real world JJ Abrams
wanted to mirror Star Wars 4 with star
wars 7 so he created a character with a
cool helmet to be the antagonist well he
certainly succeeded in that because Star
Wars 7 is just it's just a basically a
shot-for-shot remake of other Star Wars
films next I need to touch on this it is
such a common mistake when they say
they're jumping to Lightspeed they're
really entering another dimension in
which this in which the space is
compressed they calculate their route
and exit elsewhere if they couldn't do
this it would still take decades to
travel across the galaxy and lastly the
lightsaber thing first let me start by
saying that some of the characters
thought of this - such as the leader of
Death Watch from Star Wars the Clone
Wars as for us from Star Wars rebels I
don't even know what these are the room
and even Luke has a blaster and the
lightsaber in episode 5 finn in the
battle of the forest planet on the
forest planet even wishes he had a look
a blaster he fights with a lightsaber
against the stormtrooper with the
riot-control ax because the stormtrooper
wanted to make it personal the reason
that force users don't fight with
blasters is for two reasons one while
the lasers fly slowly in episode 2 we
see Jedi reflecting lasers in a chaotic
battle scene they have a sense that
allows them to block and deflect the
lasers this gives them lasers whenever
their opponent does additionally they
have better ranged offensive abilities
that being forced telekinesis they do
not use it on each other because they
cancel each other out and lastly they
use lightsabers because it is Jedi
tradition and it's been going on since
early times
okay Han drew your your answer on the
helmet was sufficient that's fine I'll
accept it I still think the good guys
could do more with the costumes
they could do themselves some favor a
favor by you know adopting not just
helmets but even capes in Star Wars a
lot of the bad guys walk around in capes
for some reason and and you know but so
if you're gonna do that
I mean if people get in the Star Wars
world if you can get away with wearing a
cape and people don't make fun of you
for it it seems like in the real world
if you saw a guy come out with a cape
and say what do you want a cape for but
if you can do that that I don't see why
the good guys don't do it - as far as
the as as far as the the ship's jumping
into another dimension instead of going
into Lightspeed okay fine but again that
still requires advanced technology
obviously and this is a galaxy where
such technology you got a ship that can
jump into another dimension and travel
across the galaxy in an instant and this
this this this ship was sitting in a
junkyard
that's how common this technology is
which brings us to the light saber bit
and I feel like you haven't answered my
challenge which is that in a world with
this kind of technology it should be
extremely easy to come up with a weapon
a personal weapon like a type of gun
that could that could defeat the dude
holding a lightsaber like I said the
only reason the laser guns don't work is
because the lasers move so slowly but if
you just came up with a regular with it
with a gun that shoots lasers at a
faster speed or even you just use a
regular gun with with lead bullets and
that travel at a regular bullet speed
and no Jedi in the galaxy will be able
to move fast enough to deflect all those
bullets so I could see using lightsabers
in a ceremonial way if it's part of your
your tradition and your culture but to
actually use it in battle given the kind
of technology that exists in this world
doesn't make any sense it's like if it'd
be like if Japanese soldiers still used
samurai swords in battle now they might
use them ceremonially but they're not
gonna actually go into battle in modern
times with a sword and by the way going
back to the technology bit here's
another thing that bothers me
c-3po is a pair
conscious sentient robot means extremely
advanced if c-3po existed in this world
he would be I mean easily far and away
the most advanced piece of technology
the most advanced piece of equipment in
the world I mean not even close the
operating system that c-3po is using is
is just beyond anything we can imagine
because it is capable of human thought
and yet he's externally he's like the
Tin Man so he's got the external build
of like a robot that maybe Toyota would
have come up with in 1992 but then
internally his his his his operating
system is way B it's like a thousands of
years and in the future that doesn't
make any sense to me I mean if you had
the technology to make a robot like that
why wouldn't you make him why make him
useless physically it would be like if I
had the most advanced engine anyone's
ever made and I put it in Fred
Flintstone's car it doesn't make any
sense so that's a problem this is from
Seth says Matt you talked last week
about social media and how much damage
it does and the compulsion you feel
towards it I have a very strong
compulsion I'm embarrassed to admit but
I'm probably on social media 6 or 7
hours a day I don't even like it that
much I just feel drawn to pick up my
phone and scroll mindlessly my question
is why do we do this why are people so
obsessed with social media why are we on
it all the time when it doesn't even
make us happy what's the reason so I was
thinking about this yesterday Seth after
I read your email and and the easiest
answer is to say the social media is an
addiction that doesn't really clarify
anything you just chalk something up to
an addiction and say oh it's an
addiction
it doesn't clarify it and also I think
it's not really true I think we could we
talked about a social media addiction I
think we mean it in a sort of colloquial
way but I don't see how using social
media could really be a clinical
addiction now you might find in the
medical community that in psychiatrists
and
they they maybe will pretend it's a real
addiction but I don't think I think you
got to draw a real distinction between
say heroin addiction and the compulsion
you feel to use heroin and the
compulsion you're filled to get on
Twitter I just don't think they're in
the same universe or same ballpark so I
don't think that answers it I think part
of what draws us to mindlessly scroll
the internet social media same thing
that draws us to mindlessly binge
Netflix and watch TV all the time and so
on and so on
watch reality TV and all this stuff I
think it's that we fear we fear thought
you know we don't want to think we don't
want to contemplate things too seriously
or too deeply we don't want to dwell on
anything very serious we certainly don't
want to think about our mortality about
death about it about the our basic human
condition so I I am becoming
increasingly convinced that's so much of
our culture so much of what we do is at
some level driven by our desire to
prevent ourselves from thinking we're
trying to prevent ourselves from
thinking and I think that's what
explains so much of what we do in this
culture it's a defense mechanism we do
all of this and we entertain ourselves
relentlessly almost obsessively because
it stops us from thinking we are very
troubled by thought and it seems that
we'd rather not have very many of them
very many thoughts that is I think we in
general are becoming very frivolous
people that's what you find in the
culture but especially in the internet
and internet culture frivolity and irony
and cynicism we obsess over dumb things
irrelevant things we're always ironic
about everything and cynical about
everything and I know it's kind of
hypocritical for me to be complaining
about that of all people but again it's
it's hard for me not to see that as at
least at some level a defense mechanism
a way to deny
to turn our heads from the really
serious business of living and thinking
and being I mean think about this
speaking of thinking prior to prior to
modern media so you know I'm talking
about prior to internet TV radio even so
for I don't know the first 10,000 years
give or take of human civilization there
was there was none of that nothing to
listen to nothing to watch or scroll
through in terms of media none of that
existed so what did people do you ever
thought about that what did they do well
they worked okay they worked a lot they
toiled and they worked fine and that was
a lot of their day and maybe they read
although if you go back far enough
literacy was pretty uncommon and they
didn't have the same access and you go
all the way back to before the printing
press they didn't you know people didn't
have access to books unless you were a
monk or a you know someone in the elite
class so maybe a read maybe you did some
reading and but what else what else do
they do with their free time at the end
of the day you got your work done for
the day
it's not time for bed yet what are you
doing I'm sure they talk to each other
I'm sure they spend time as a family
they played games and so on
but the point I'm getting to here is
that there was probably time there's
probably lots of time cumulative Lee
where they sat there and didn't do
anything
there was probably a fair amount of
sitting silently in doing nothing that
was probably a relatively normal part of
human existence for thousands of years
where there would be times in the day
when you know a you there was nothing
really to do is you've sat there and you
know maybe you just did nothing
maybe not for thought not for six hours
but there would be time in the day
because you didn't have a phone to pull
out distract yourself you didn't have a
TV to turn on and you're sitting on a
piece of furniture in your living room
and you're just sitting there thinking
now when was the last time that you did
that what was the last time that you sat
somewhere no phone no TV not talking to
anybody not doing anything not flipping
through a magazine nothing he just sat
there and you thought when's the last
time you did that
I bet for a lot of us it's been like
years since we've done that and in the
times when we feel like we're forced to
it to do it we panic like have you ever
been in a situation maybe you're in a
waiting room and there's no good
magazines to read and your phone is dead
and they don't have a TV and you're
sitting there waiting for the dentist to
call you back and you've got nothing to
do and you know you've got your phone in
your hand and you feel this compulsion
to look at it but it's dead it creates a
real sense of almost like panic like
you've been disconnected from something
and the idea that all you can do is
simply sit there is is overwhelming
we're really uncomfortable with it and
why are we uncomfortable with it the
only explanation I can come up with is
that it allows for a lot of
unadulterated unfiltered thinking and we
don't like that we're afraid of our own
thoughts so that III think that's that's
part of it maybe we've even forgotten
how to think in some ways because we've
out sourced our thinking to the Internet
we let the internet think for us maybe
we let the internet literally complete
our sentences for us
all right from Lee says hi Matt loved
the show wanted to know how you feel
about reincarnation if you believe in
the afterlife why do you rule out the
possibility of reincarnation billions of
people believe that we will be
reincarnated after death do you think
this is possible or have you ruled it
out if so why well first of all it's not
up to me to rule anything out per se I
mean when we die whatever happens
happens so I can't rule it out or rule
it in it is what it is now as far as
what I think about it well in a certain
sense yeah we are reincarnated in the
sense that our bodies are made up of
atoms seven billion billion billion
atoms to be precise or sort of precise
and when we die those atoms don't die
with us they are recycled back into the
world and they become other things just
like the atoms in our body right now
were other things and and if you trace
it back far enough our you know as Carl
Sagan talks about we are the stuff of
stars we are literally Stardust we were
made from stars and we are in a sense
you might say reincarnated stars so if
you want to look at it physically at the
atomic level then okay I guess I think
it's weird to call that reincarnation
but I you could make some sort of
argument for that but that's not what
you mean by reincarnation I assume
reincarnation means when you brink talk
about it it means some mysterious
mystical way that your actual essence
your being you as a person continue to
live on in another form after this form
dies right that's what you mean
now to me that's disqualified on a
logical basis I don't even need to get
anything else I think it's just it
doesn't make any logical sense and I'll
explain why because if if reincarnation
is true then I right now in just the
latest version of myself I had other
selves before this one and those other
selves screwed up so badly that they got
sent back to earth in my body those poor
bastards but what does that mean if I
other selves yet those other selves had
different physical forms different
personalities different experiences
different beliefs and different
everything different family different
everything and I can't remember those
past selves and thus I don't have any of
their memories then in what sense
exactly are we the same exactly in what
sense
am i that past self it doesn't even mean
anything I'm a completely different
person with a whole new set of
experiences and everything where is the
continuity and and what exactly would be
I guess this is really the point what
exactly would be the difference between
me dying and being obliterated and me
dying and coming back quote-unquote as
an entirely new person with no memory of
my past experiences isn't it the same
thing as obliteration I mean think about
even if you let's let's let's even make
it less extreme let's say that there was
a you know some sort of technology where
you where they're able to you know
obliterate your mind and implant a new
mind into into into your body somehow
let's say that technology existed you
know no memory anymore of your past self
completely new personality completely
new everything although you still have
the same body isn't that the same effect
of like leading up to that you as you're
waiting for yourself to be obliterated
and and have this new self implanted in
with this crazy technology that pass
isn't that the same thing as death
basically now if you were to consider
that your body is obliterated to and now
you have a new mind and a new body then
it's okay that's just I don't even see
how we could call that reincarnation so
that's that's my my issue with it I just
I don't see the difference you know I
know there are people who claim oh I
have memories of my past selves first of
all no you don't but second of all
not enough of a memory for there to be
any continuity so that it again it just
ends up being the same thing effectively
as there being no reincarnation at all
all right that's how I feel about
reincarnation it will leave on that note
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Robin Fenderson the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
Ben Shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there